hey there welcome to Conan O'Brien needs
a friend
our setup today is a little different uh
usually
um myself Matt Gourley and Sona mosesian
we're all in the same room uh this is a
little bit of a different occasion I am
in New York City
because I came here to do some uh well
some pretty cool interviews I had a
really good time yeah nice and oh big
big stars happy for you huge Stars huge
stars
um but I came here to do that and uh you
guys remained in Los Angeles uh you you
know it's a lot of money to fly you guys
out here and uh we didn't want to spend
that kind of coin it's worth it
um not really Elevate the content can I
put a price on on charm yeah you
actually you can you can put a price on
charm and it's not equal to if you were
willing to uh fly coach actually if you
would do that I know I know this arm
like this don't feel like coach
laughs
so anyway I'm here in New York and uh my
charming uh pals are in Los Angeles at
the moment so we're on what's called
this might be new to some of you it's
called Zoom and uh it's a technology
that really uh exploded during covid
this is a Revival of our covid days when
we yeah we're doing the podcast and we
weren't all in the same room so let me
just put it to you guys
um do you feel that our energy is
different when say we're in in different
spaces Gorly you're in your you're in
your wonderful home in Pasadena and Sona
you're in a land called Altadena
um north of Pasadena it doesn't show
yeah never seen it on a map anyway
um it's like those old maps from the
16th century where they just show
dragons and stuff you look at Maps often
you just
maps and since if you can find the
cities people live in yes I do and when
you said I live in Altadena I couldn't
find it on a map and then I asked an old
man and he said don't go that way
death and doom aways you
see creatures
um no it's a lovely place and I'm just
kidding around but anyway we're in
different zones yeah right now I can say
I feel safer having you at a distance
but the the magic isn't as you know
clicky clicky you know I hate this why
do you hate it I hate this a lot I like
you being I like you being confined to
this small box
hey I'm turning your volume down right
now it's fantastic I'm here and like I'm
I'm only thinking about like are my boys
napping and then when I'm in the studio
I don't think about that sounds like a
euphemism
yeah I know my boys are taking a little
snooze wait but you feminism for what
though what does that mean the testicles
my testicles are asleep oh you call your
testicles your boys I say hey Mike and
they've been asleep for years yeah
they've been trust me my testicles went
soundly asleep I think it was 1989. they
passed out they're having a good long
sleepy weepy
sometimes I'm at a loud party and I'm
like guys keep it down my boys are
sleeping
I'd say that all the time hey Sona think
of all the amazing things in life that
are expressions of just you yeah I mean
like the chocolate that you had on your
face when you came in because you just
ate that what was it you were eating I
was eating a giant cookie giant cookie
yeah and that's so Sona okay or that
song you stream over and over again it's
just so you what's that song For You
Twinkle Twinkle Little Star yeah but
it's for my boys I know still it's nice
okay or you know that podcast that
comedy podcast you just gotta listen to
yeah Conan O'Brien needs a friend
exactly is that what you listen to in
your spare time yeah I love it
everything that makes you you makes all
the difference State Farm believes
Insurance should work the same way your
plan your coverage selections could be
personalized by you and only you that's
cool I shouldn't shout but this is how
strong away I feel about it you better
choose the plan you want by picking the
options that fit you like choosing to
bundle your home and auto policies is
what the State Farm personal price plan
is all about getting the coverage you
want at an affordable price just for you
call or go to statefarm.com today to
create your State Farm personal price
plan prices vary by state options
selected by customers availability and
eligibility may vary see this is the
kind of magic we wouldn't have had if we
were on the studio go together but
because because we're all in separate
spaces I feel comfortable when Sona when
you bring up your children immediately
making it about my testicles and that's
the kind of magic that in person no I'm
very proper when we're in prison oh
you're a proper guy I'm a proper boy oh
I love when you do your character work
who's this character yeah who's this
Conan as a proper guy let me hear it oh
I'm calling it I'm I'm cold and properly
okay now do your proper thing a french
guy oh yes
[Applause]
oh my God it's the worst character work
of all time
[Laughter]
I would like to apologize
can you do better can you do a better
friendship no I can't that's who could
top that that is a French hand that's a
French Canadian cartoon I think you're
doing yeah
[Music]
oh no that's good collaborator
y
hold on my gosh guys shut up
mouths real quick
come on now you got German now that's
the German right there are you like the
broadcast
please and I encourage you to go look at
the video of this because Sona is
putting her whole body into it and
um good guy that's great so no that was
fantastic fantastic and I mean that yeah
not in the way you think
um no what a delight what a delight uh
hey I love this this was amazing now
we're gonna get to the interview part
and for the interview
we are all together for that because we
take we better hurry up and get there
everybody
you gotta fly back
no okay oh it's funny when Matt does it
okay no it wasn't funny
I don't know what that was what was that
I love that none of you were my
impression of your persona doing a
French person yes that was my German guy
come on my boys are getting anxious
they're awake boys they just woke up oh
no they're like they don't know what's
been happening since 1989.
George Bush's son became president
is quiet
there's more and then Trump what the
real estate from the real ocean
quiet testicles quiet unique yeah well
they are pretty mean they are pretty me
I love that that's how my my
[Music]
name
here